good morning believe nation today's
message is understand others over to you
Evan pagan awake the TV goes the more
you seek to understand the more you
really do that proactively try to
empathize with another person and feel
compassion and see it from their
perspective and say more you understand
yourself well the more you understand
yourself but the more you dissolves I
understand right and the more you start
to realize oh wait a minute there's a
bigger game here we're all on the space
terrarium right flying around the Sun at
18 miles a second and around the galaxy
it you know what is it 150 miles a
second and it's this delicate little
balance and we've got to wake up and
we've got to help each other we've got
to solve our significant problems I got
to stop worrying about how to get better
clothes or a nicer car or make someone
you know approve of me and I've got to
start helping other people and what's
miraculous is when you start
understanding other people and then you
start helping other people you become
more fulfilled they become more
fulfilled you start dissolving a little
bit and becoming more integrated you
feel more at home on your own planet and
I think that anything you can contribute
to the greater this is a really
important message for anybody trying to
grow business because you have to
understand your customers the media
partners investors anybody who has
anything to do with your business you
deal with people so you have to
understand them you cannot do this alone
and the more you try the less likely
you're going to be able to achieve your
goals I want to talk about it in the
context today they'll building a team
because one thing that really helps you
is having your one word having a thing
that you staying for being front and
center and that helps to attract the
right kind of people to your business as
an example in my company I believe in
entrepreneurs right if you don't believe
in entrepreneurs you're not going to fit
in well at my business right you're not
gonna have a good time you're not going
to produce amazing results you're not
going to feel happy if you don't love
believing in entrepreneurs and so
already just from standing for something
important I attract the right
to my company but still within that I
have to understand what motivates each
of the people on my team right we've got
16 people on the team everybody is
motivated by different things some
people are very creative I need creative
outlets for their ideas some people
don't like being creative and like being
told what to do some people want to be
paid based on performance and as their
projects do better they make more money
but if it doesn't do well they don't get
a lot of money some people hate that
risk and they just want to get paid a
fixed salary and they know what income
is coming in every week and so you need
to understand your team understand the
people who are working for you and build
an environment that is best suited to
each of them because it helps you
accomplish your big goal so my question
the day for you is I want to know what
you've done to try to understand people
better leave it in the comments below
I'm curious to see what you have to say
thank you so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events press over this
bridge to keep me go